all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa i have two
all-form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get 20 off when you go
to allform.com
pacman
so we have another new headline about
the spending bill slash infrastructure
bill discussion that continues to i
don't want to be negative but it sort of
is like plaguing us at this point the
fact that
it's discussion and grandstanding and
people getting attention for
getting uh getting attention for
opposing things that they should be in
favor of um but maybe this is good news
and the news is that house democrats
have put
paid family leave back into the spending
bill
now
i'm going to tell you what the news is
and i'm going to tell you what's being
said but my view on this
is that this it's in and of itself may
be grandstanding and i don't know if i'm
at this point just
jaded and cynical you'll have to tell me
but we'll get to that
remember the context is that even as
things were completely falling apart
bernie sanders went on tv over the
weekend and said hey i'm still working
on the prescription drug cost control
aspect of this
and then on tuesday it was announced hey
the prescription drug control component
is back in the bill we talked about that
a couple of days ago
now the news is house democrats put paid
family leave back into the bill uh the
hill reporting house democrats have
amended the enormous social spending
framework at the heart of president
biden's economic agenda to include paid
family leave a popular provision that
had met resistance from senator joe
manchin and was thought to be removed
the change was announced wednesday
morning in a letter from speaker pelosi
who said the house rules committee would
meet later in the day to consider the
changes but pelosi stopped short of
announcing the vote on the package
instead the speaker said there remain a
few outstanding issues
it has been my intention through the
process to put on the house floor and
pass a bill that would pass the senate
in the same form because i've been
informed by a senator of opposition
to a few of the priorities contained in
our bill and because we must have
legislation agreed to by the house and
senate in the final version of build
back better that we we will send to the
president's desk we must strive to find
common ground biden initially proposed
12 weeks of paid family leave
a provision adopted by house democrats
but mansion balked at the 494 billion
dollar price tag forcing negotiators to
consider a sharp reduction down to four
weeks before biden slashed it all
together progressives grumbled
and said they would accept the they
would accept it as a cost of enacting
other social benefits pelosi on
wednesday however said paid leave would
be part of the house rules committee's
discussion
the decision can it came at the urging
of many members of the
caucus
chairman richie neil and the committee
staff have worked on this priority for a
long time and were ready the provision
will provide four weeks not the twelve
four weeks of permanent parental and
medical leave according to an aide
familiar with the language
alex bolton reporting mansion not
thrilled to hear speaker pelosi has
added four weeks of paid leave back in
bbb
that's a challenge and they know how i
feel about it
so okay uh first of all
this isn't the infrastructure bill this
is the 2022 budget bill labeled build
back better or bbb
there's confusion between the two
without a doubt often it's not really
they just say the bill
um so there's confusion but this is the
build back better bill now in an ideal
world everything would be in its own
bill so you say okay let's do a bill for
paid family leave who's for it who's
against it okay you figure it out
um the problem is that if you did that
a whole bunch of stuff would just never
pass the whole system we have is this
pseudo-corrupt system of cronyism and
earmarks and pork
where people
in the house and senate
agree to support x as long as y is in
there
um and that's sort of like a for better
or for worse thing that's why we get
these packages with so many things in
there
now
there are real questions as to how these
four weeks would even work do you have
to pay into it or not what counts as
leave what's a worker what about gig
workers what about self-employed people
independent contractors does it only
apply to w-2 we just don't know and
what's the future of this we have
absolutely no idea what i know is two
things and this is where i want to go
back to my am i being too cynical
time is running out to get this done
this calendar year to get this done
before the house and senate recess for
the end of the year
i am starting to wonder whether things
are getting added back in
so that it looks better as a bill
that's not going to pass what i mean by
that is
one perspective is that buildback better
is dead that the build back better act
at least in 2021 is not going to pass
so thinking very cynically
are they making the bill more robust so
that when it doesn't pass they can say
look we
we put our best foot forward we added
prescription drug controls
we added some paid leave so that the
bill looks better to progressives
knowing that the bill is essentially
dead
they will
not pass
a better bill
rather than not pass
a crappier bill
i don't know
um it's all disappointing
uh this has been going on for months at
this point these are all things that
should not be controversial in a country
as rich as the united states these
things aren't controversial in most
other countries that are level of wealth
but let me know if you think i'm being
too cynical about now they're just
trying to make the bill better before
not passing it to say
it would have been a pretty good bill
but it has no chance of passing let me
know what you think
i have disturbing video for you today
of ron desantis appearing on fox news
with a kid who says that
masks are bad basically
and this looks like a hostage video
it it looks like i mean listen i'm going
to play it for you it's only 10 seconds
we'll look at it a couple of times
this looks like a hostage video where
the kid barely has any idea what they're
being forced to say and ron desantis
republican florida governor
um
looks
so smug
let's just look and listen to this um
and then then we'll see if we can make
heads or tails out of it go ahead i'm
not wearing a mask because you touch it
and you have germs on your hand and then
you put it on your face and breathe in
all the germs that's right and and
okay and listen there's steve ducey i
think saying that's right that's right
so
uh this is fiona lachelles a second
grader in florida
and of course when we think about public
policy
my instinct always is ask one second
greater what they think
and make that the policy
now something about this video is
extremely disturbing but many things
about the video are extremely disturbing
republicans seem to have found a way
to put kids front and center on masks
and not wanting them
notice that they never put front and
center
the kids of parents who died
unvaccinated of covid i wish they got
the same prominent placement as fiona
lachelle's saying i don't want to wear
the mask let's listen to it one more
time go ahead i'm not wearing a mask
because you touch it and you have germs
on your hand and then you put it on your
face and breathe in all the germs and
ron desantis just looks so thrilled now
it's been
we we have two options we could ask a
second grader
hand picked by ron desantis their
opinion of masks or we could look at the
studies
um
endless endless endless studies on this
do face masks work 49 scientific studies
explain why they do
you can go to
jama insights
they have a meta-analysis called
effectiveness of mass squaring to
control community spread of sars-ko v2
they actually look at all of these
different studies
and they find
significant decreases
in the spread of covid you can download
this it's a free study you can find it
and they write increasing number of
ecological studies also provide
persuasive evidence that universal
masking reduces the number of infections
and deaths these studies don't
distinguish the type of masks but they
all seem to work to some degree
the overall community benefit of wearing
masks derives from their ability to
limit both exhalation and inhalation of
infectious virus the science on masks
and then
a second grader hand-picked by ron
desantis sorry about that
um let's let's just listen to it one
more time this is is this child abuse in
some way go ahead i'm not wearing a mask
because you touch it and you have germs
on your hand and then you put it on your
face and breathe in all the germs yeah
and that's importantly this is a second
grader suspended 36 days for not wearing
a mask one just little bonus clip for
you from florida just to tell you how
crazy things in florida are
this is 14 seconds of a video of ron
desantis announcing he's going to create
an office to investigate election crimes
in florida what crimes are even being
alleged in florida election crimes i
don't know trump won florida by three
and a half
no one's even really talking about
florida fraud and when ron desantis
announces so so think about the layers
desantis mishandles covid
announces he's creating an office to
investigate election crimes which we
don't need
and then the crowd starts cheering and
chanting let's go brandon
[Applause]
just completely cringy now if you don't
know about let's go brandon it goes back
to a nascar race during which uh there
were people in the crowd during an
interview chanting f joe biden
and the reporter misheard it she was
interviewing a race car driver named
brandon and she said look they're
chanting let's go brandon but really
they were chanting f joe biden that's
where it comes from it's it's not very
funny um it's almost like a rallying cry
of ignorance and stupidity but
when ron it's fitting that ron desantis
announces an investigation into
something we don't need
and the crowd starts chanting let's go
brandon so just horrifying horrifying
stuff happening in florida we've got a
great show for you today uh let me know
your thoughts on the desantis child
hostage video you can find me on twitter
at d pacman we're going to take some of
your calls look at some of your emails
and many many exciting things happening
today
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get 20 off when you go to all form dot
com slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show
depends on the support of viewers and
listeners who sign up and get a
membership at joinpakman.com we produce
an extra show every day for our members
it's called the bonus show it's won a
number of awards they are awards i
created
it's sort of like when rand paul
created his own ophthalmology
organization
as an ophthalmologist but much more
moral let's put it that way sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code better21 to get a discount let's
hear from some people in the audience we
now take calls via discord it just works
better it works better than the things
we used to do you can find the discord
at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go
first
to kevin from grand rapids presumably is
that michigan kevin
kevin from grand rapids you are on the
air
and last chance for kevin from grand
rapids kevin please
hello
you're on the air
you can hear me
now i can
oh thank you hey david great to have a
call uh first time caller thank you um
yeah i'm calling uh
i don't really i kind of not starting
off on a super topical one because i
know the elections happened last night
and um you know that's kind of a lot to
talk about but i had a question um kind
of a general one
would you um agree that it seems like
people on the right are a lot more um
organized as one these days
in a sense that like they seem to agree
and like
work towards goals at least
slightly or mostly better than people on
the left do and what we could do to
maybe
come together and start to have some of
that presence that people on the right
seem to be getting one up us on us with
like i don't know i consider myself a
self a democratic socialist but i know
that there's a lot of people
like uh people are a little more liberal
than i am that might like we might
disagree on certain things i don't need
to get into specific specifics of it but
i just i kind of think that
it seems like the left is a little less
cohesive and together
and a little bit more prone to like
nitpicking things i think you're right
kevin i've got a few videos on this um
and indeed i do think that there are
some on the left who sometimes uh let
the perfect become the enemy of the good
it's definitely an important issue and
one i've talked about but kevin i i'm
going to let you go because that smoke
detector that you got to deal with that
okay my friend so
that happened last night i got to get a
nine volt battery exactly yep all right
thank you kev very good we've got a lot
happening there and i'm going to let him
get to it let's go next to isaiah from
arkansas isaiah you are on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
um well i have a question but
first i'm going to kind of follow up
with what kevin said
um in
there's definitely an issue
with
democrats just being terrible at
campaigning effectively that was kind of
my conclusion from
virginia
and new jersey yeah
and in the state of arkansas where you
know we have like five democrats elected
in the entire state anywhere
there is just so much incompetence
and so much of
anybody working
um so i don't want to take too long but
to
kind of say quickly
i was in a i was in a group i'm in
college i was in a group that was um
or like electing like a young democrats
group
and i said that based on
how
disorganized the party is right now we
should be focusing on
um voting in the in the
republican primaries to keep out the
extremists because in arkansas you can
you have to pick which primary you vote
in right and i got kicked out of that
group
for as they said spreading republican
propaganda
so like if a basic thing like that
of strategy they're kicking out people
how do you expect to accomplish anything
sure of course that's the total thing
well um voting in democrat in republican
primaries when states allow you to vote
in either as a way to keep out the worst
candidate is a much discussed strategy
that has been talked about for a while i
think it's certainly a very interesting
one i think you're absolutely right that
part of what went wrong in virginia is
uh
that republicans are at a structural
advantage it's much easier to motivate
people to vote based on anger and fear
in virginia a lot of it was about
education and critical race theory
and
fear and anger are just better
motivators to get people to engage with
the system and that's something that the
right uses significantly in this country
so i i think your analysis is exactly
right
and in arkansas i might be wrong about
this but i believe you have to either
vote in the republican or the democrat
you can't vote in both in the primary
yeah i think that's the case in uh
that's i believe that's the case in
every state you can't vote in both
primaries yeah we have
the the fact of the matter is as it
stands in 2022 the election is in march
whoever wins the republican primaries in
in the office pretty much is going to
win in november and we have i think a
character i don't know if you're
familiar with them but i think you'll be
more familiar with them in the future
have you heard of jason or rapert no
he is a real lunatic
state senator we have that's running for
lieutenant governor
and
anyone listening just read the wikipedia
article on them kind of speaks for
itself but i don't want to take up too
much of your time but my question is for
someone like me living in arkansas
i think
obviously i'm
kind of moderate left
you if you want to say i think the most
effective way
to actually change
the uh political demographics of the
state is or do you think it's just a
better to just get out all together
that's it's your call as to whether you
want to get out or not it wouldn't be
illegitimate to get out if you decide
that you just want to improve your
circumstances immediately rather than
work to improve everybody's in your
state but get in find local races find
candidates that are that are doing the
right things as far as you're concerned
um and get get involved in those
campaigns is the best advice i can give
all right my friend i'm going to move on
because i've got a lot of people waiting
to chat let's go next to jill from
burbank california jill you were on the
air
jill from burbank california please
unmute yourself and then we'll be able
to hear you
hey can you hear me
yes
okay uh big fan um two things uh i
wanted to uh talk about one was jesse
lee peterson
uh it was fascinating to watch you
debate him um but
my point is
that he doesn't think that he's wrong
after even
uh you you know confronted him
and
you know basically showed him that he's
uh he's in he doesn't know anything
about
uh his
stance right um
what do you think we should do
to people like that because
should we even engage because
uh
he's the biggest
example i think
for people
even
after you
show them the facts and tell them
that he you know they have no stance
they go and
they have they have their show and they
have their own um
day-to-day
and they continue
yeah i don't think it's so much about
convincing jessie lee peterson it's more
is it worth doing so that maybe people
in the audience see
how quickly his assertions fall apart
and crumble
i don't go in thinking the goal here is
to convince jesse lee peterson to change
his mind it's let's just show how silly
and cartoonish his entire perspective is
you know so i think it's just we have to
manage what the expectation is i wasn't
i wasn't trying to change his mind
right yeah
but i mean you you had one person come
back and say oh i'm i'm a democrat now
and you know not a republican anymore
which is which is a good thing i think
maybe yeah people saw it and maybe they
changed their minds as a result of
seeing it for sure i think that's really
the goal it's for the audience rather
than for jesse lee peterson
but now in the tuesday election uh
you know that you know yunkan juan i
think it was
a few things like the crt which is not
you know taught anywhere but they made
made a boogeyman out of
nothing just like
trump did out of a cara you know cara
event is coming
and he tried to do it in the midterms as
well
um
but what do you think
like why can't democrats also
make a boogeyman out of
something that republicans do
it's just not clear democrats would fall
for it like what would they what would
they do what would they do oh
republicans want to ban abortion well
it's like well most of them do it's not
you know what like what would you what
would the boogeyman be you know
anything like that yeah exactly like
abortion or um
uh
you know our child care uh
that we are basically at
at the end of the list uh on
in the in the
in the world uh yeah it just doesn't
seem to create so many points it doesn't
seem to create the fear and anger
that
motivates these republicans to get out
and vote let me think about whether
there is such an issue it's an
interesting idea jill but i just don't
know if it would work let me think about
it
those are the two thank you uh keep on
doing what you're doing uh i'm gonna
switch from uh tcyt to you uh my uh
uh twitch sub oh wow thank you so much
for everything all right thanks jill
appreciate it there's jill from burbank
very very strongly presenting a number
of different arguments
let's go
next to tim from wisconsin tim you are
on the air next
hey david can you hear me yes i can
excellent
um
let's see i guess i'm a little bit
concerned with um
all the school boards lately where you
keep on seeing these
threats of violence um is there a
threshold in your mind that
we really need to be
you know taking some defensive action or
doing something what do you mean you're
saying to like security at school board
meetings or do you mean political uh
defense
more physical like security yeah i mean
that's it we're probably already past
that threshold to be totally honest i
think that there are some places that
have gone to closed school board
meetings they've eliminated this like
audience commentary portion to make it
safer
but i think we're already there and you
know it really varies it depends on the
school district but i think we're
already at the point where physical
security has to be a concern
fair enough yeah sadly unfortunately
all right that's all i had all right
thanks very much for the call i
appreciate that
a lot of a lot of good good topics today
let's go to ej from the philippines ej
you are on the air
hello
hello
hey can
i be heard just barely
what was your question today let's see
if we can get through it
okay so my question is that
it's about
20 25 elections well i know it's a bit
far away
but i want to ask you
if
biden won't run again in 2024 i don't
know yet
this
yeah hypothetical it's a hypothetical oh
okay okay
he
won't
if he won't run again in 2025 then paris
chose
hat in the nomination
should she be
i think she should be primary
oh um
i am not
i i would never say
there should be no primary i mean if
yeah primary if there's a good candidate
if joe biden doesn't run and kamala runs
um if somebody wants to primary her they
absolutely should do it i mean i've
already said
i don't think it looks that good for
kamala harris if she becomes the nominee
because joe biden doesn't run but there
should be
we have a system
um
primary whoever you want i i'm not going
to be the one saying don't do it no
okay
i did agree with you on that that
will never be a good candidate to be
battling against trump in 2010
well we don't know if it will be against
trump importantly but i just don't see
kamala based on her persistently low
approval rating and her lack of tangible
accomplishments so far still a long time
to go of course um it's not feeling to
me like she would be a super strong
candidate in 2024 but i could be wrong
we still got three years to go
fair enough and it's just in my two
cents my opinion
okay good how are things in the
philippines otherwise okay
not really no what what's what's going
on
election
also here next year
the presidency the vice presidency and
other
political positions yeah it sounds
you're not a duterte fan it sounds like
yes
you're not i mean i was i was at first
but then
i lost he kind of lost my respect fair
yeah mine too ej thank you for the call
i really appreciate it
all right very good there is ej from the
philippines we're going to take a very
quick break if you're holding on to talk
to me
don't hang up because i'm going right
back to the phones in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
let's get back to the phones and speak
to a few more people you can join the
discord through which we take phone
calls at davidpakman.com
discord it's a great system it really
really is
why don't we go next to dean from the
state of ohio dean you are on the air
hello hello hear me yes i can
oh um hi uh first time caller thank you
glad to talk to you david pleasure and
um i am a
current college student in a pl um a um
basically a comp side class comparative
politics and i was curious on your
opinion on parliamentary democracies
because right now in the u.s we have
kind of a
very strong gridlock in our senate
system and i'm not obviously i prefer
presidential systems but you know if we
had a parliamentary democracy where we
could i guess effectively get more
things done do you think the u.s would
be a better or worse country for it it's
kind of a broad question my general
belief on this and i've i've talked
about it a little bit before is that i
think that a parliamentary system would
bring
actually many good things to the united
states where you would have um you know
a system where you have the leader of
the party with the greatest
representation in the legislature
becoming typically it would be like the
prime minister minister or the
chancellor rather than a directly
elected uh president
um i i generally think it would be an
improvement for the united states
although i've had
some concerns that there's a lot of
really crazy extremists here and that
really
horrible uh parties which have no
official representation right now could
end up having some official
representation and that there's
certainly a danger to that um but you
know it's a very hypothetical it's it's
merely an academic question because the
u.s is not going to change to a
parliamentary system anytime soon i i'm
not like trump where i go the u.s will
never
at no point soon right at no point soon
and so i think that we have to try to
improve things in other in other ways
of course
yeah but no i i like parliamentary
systems as a general principle
and um i guess there's a slight addendum
to that question we have a mix in the us
of a single member districts that we
elect and to represent people and then
we have a proportional system yes do you
think we would be better off if we went
to a 100 proportional i know there's
pros and cons of both but it just seems
like we have a senate that
disproportionately represents
republicans even though they have less
percentage overall in the united states
yeah the senate is fundamentally
anti-democratic i've talked about this
before it's not representative you have
um
something like uh
the senators representing i'm trying to
get the number right it's like 34 of the
population senators representing 34 of
the population
control half of the votes which is
fundamentally unrepresentative and
undemocratic again it's one of these
things where there's no way to deny that
that's the case and it's just not going
to change anytime soon and so i wonder
about
the
prudency of focusing on it i want to
make sure people understand this the
senate is fundamentally not democratic
and not representative
but
okay so then what do we do with that and
do we just focus on that and ignore
everything else that we could be working
on that doesn't seem prudent either
but but of course david um my apologies
i will try to come if i call again next
time to get a more um pragmatic question
i i was more of an actor
i'm not criticizing it i'm only making
it like in other words i'm saying
you are 100 spot on about these issues
and i agree with you and i talk about
them as well
and i wonder what is the balance of like
activism capital that should be spent on
one thing versus the other when these
things seem very ingrained now the
counterpoint would be david if you don't
try to activate around these things
they're going to remain the way they are
and that's a good point too you know so
i don't know where our pragmatic versus
idealist balance should be
thank you so much david my pleasure all
right uh extraordinary phone call there
uh love it
let's go
next
to
um
michael
from berlin new jersey michael you're
next
hi david how you doing
i'm doing all right you sound like
you're talking through a voice modulator
i know
a headset okay what's going on
i just wanted to uh i guess
uh explain some experience at the polls
yesterday i uh
i uh i
worked as a poll worker
uh in new jersey and i just wanted to uh
explain my experience that it was
actually a great experience
it felt like i was really doing a
democratic
thing okay unfortunately um it didn't
work out the way i wanted it
wanted it to but but that's okay because
i felt like i actually
did my duty so um
are you curious were there poll workers
trying to electioneer in some way during
during their work
yeah we did actually have a problem they
were within the 100 foot zone
and people were complaining outside
but those were poll workers or these
were just people people trying to
campaign there
campaign absolutely okay okay did you
have any issues like on uh le there was
this video there was a picture of some
guy all magged out
working the polls you didn't have
anything like that
that's good yeah thankfully not yeah uh
but we were in a
rural area in new jersey so uh
like close to the pine barrens so
maybe you would have that in the um like
in the big city maybe or or in the
suburban area okay
um
what i like
we were in teams like you couldn't just
be a poll worker and not have a like
i was in charge of bringing the votes
back into the central location
the town hall and i was teamed up with a
republican and
it happened to be a woman actually i was
the only male in the whole group out of
12 i was going male
and
actually turned out to be a great thing
um
and she was such a
what was it she was definitely the
opposite of a low information person
like she was very positive she's very
capable
and confident so i mean i guess i was
i'm
i'm thinking that negatively about
republicans
she i i just couldn't believe that she
was a republican that's how competent
and uh she just wanted to share that
that she was very
i don't know competent and i would
gladly work with her again
now i'm curious why was it even coming
up what people's party affiliations were
in other words isn't it what is it
because there's supposed to be a split
of democrats and republicans
yes right if you return i was
responsible for returning
the ballots right and you can't do that
by yourself you have to have
a fair delegation so you have to have a
republican and a democrat got it got it
all right very good well it sounds like
it was a good experience i would
encourage more people to um to become
poll workers
yes i would do i would do the same thank
you beautiful all right michael from
berlin new jersey great to hear from you
uh a lot of people in fact uh in the
audience
emailed me and said david i was a poll
worker here i was a poll worker there uh
quite quite compelling stuff
let's go next to dan from the united
kingdom dan you're on the air
hi david can you hear me i can
oh that's good i'm on my airpods so if
the sound goes i'm sorry um i kind of
had a couple of questions um sorry if i
ramble a bit um one kind of concern sort
of political apathy um because i'm aware
i only basically followed this because
if we obviously got our own troubles
over here the virginia governor race i
noted that there was about
um 3.3 million votes in the in that race
and that's kind of a high compared to
sort of previous elections but right
when you think about that in sort of
comparison to the presidential election
that was kind of a million votes lower
and then when you think about sort of
primary votes um more broadly they're
often
sort of miles lower than the actual
general election but that's where you
can kind of get the most
ideological diversity amongst the
parties and you could probably get the
most change how do you think we could so
or how we i mean countries more general
where you've got sort of
forty percent of the pop of the public
not voting even in the main elections
sometimes elections can barely get 20 of
the vote
and they control a lot of power so i
don't know what your thoughts are on
that one so listen there's a couple
different answers to this one answer is
that
i the idealistic answer would be well
listen uh the way we get people
interested here dan is we have to make
sure everybody understands the direct
link between they're going out to vote
even in midterms and local municipal
elections and the things that happen in
their community as soon as you explain
this to people you're gonna see voter
turnout increase dramatically it's kind
of bs in the sense that it's been tried
so many ways and it just never really
seems to work like there's just no
turnout in the us and then there's even
lower turnout for midterms it's just
there's just lower turnout and the
problem with that is that it
disproportionately helps whoever can be
the most salacious
in their campaign and in virginia it was
republicans who used fear and anger to
get republican voters out to fight
critical race theory which they wrongly
believe is being taught in schools so my
real answer would be like the idealistic
answer is let's just explain to people
how important it is to participate it
doesn't really work very well
a lot of people see it almost as a badge
of honor that they don't work they don't
they don't vote rather some people see
it as a badge of honor not to work but
we're talking about voting here they see
it as a badge of honor not to vote and
if voting is not mandatory that's uh
considered completely valid and that's
that's that's the way it is so the next
step would be well just you make voting
mandatory like it is in many countries
yeah i just don't think you're going to
see it in the u.s i think it goes
against sort of like the idea of the of
the funding fundamental principles of
the united states wouldn't even happen
yeah right exactly it wouldn't even
happen so that wouldn't happen i think
where we end up unfortunately dan is
we have to accept that 40 percent of
eligible voters won't vote in
presidential elections and 60 won't vote
in midterms and you just have to figure
out how do you win and achieve change
given that uh reality uh it's it's it's
depressing i know but i think that
that's where we're yeah no
um i don't know if you've got time for
one more um it was kind of sort of
linked to this it's i guess like when
you kind of you can i guess in any
election you might get sort of a dozen
or so called broad categories of policy
discussed that often that as you've kind
of talked about something like critical
race theory or the opposition to
teaching of something which isn't really
taught yeah is i guess if you if you
kind of line up things by sort of the
harm they cause i guess climate change
could be one corruption could be another
lack of health care and so on but these
sometimes can get the least kind of
they're the ones that do the most damage
where they get the least focus is there
kind of is there a way of sort of like
as maybe as activists or that's
convincing of media changing the media
environment how do you kind of reach
sort of
is there a way to recalibrate a sort of
public discourse to focus on things that
cause sort of the most heart
rather than something like you know like
the result the risk of dying from
covered in like a hundred times or if
that's greater than being killed
unfortunately unless you change the
infrastructure around how corporate
media works you're not going to change
that because when you have profit-driven
media that wants to focus on the most
salacious and titillating stories
unless you change the fact that there's
a big reward for that i don't know how
you make the changes to the discourse
that you're talking about i mean part of
it would be counter options so we've
seen the growth of long-form podcast
discussions and all these different
things and that's great but it's also
great because it's profitable too right
if it were completely not viable then
you wouldn't see that either so that's
more of a cultural thing i don't think
you change it by changing media i think
media will change as the culture changes
around what's profitable and what what
gets eyeballs
yeah no i have to i often kind of move
towards like sometimes i don't listen to
sort of long-form podcasts or long-form
discussions about a single topic rather
than sort of like by clickbait
headlines because they don't really go
into any debt so i kind of try and
diversify what i'm listening to beyond
just typical headlines although so the
bbc does a decent job here they may not
be brilliant but at least they're not
like
that you can get in-depth explainers on
there so they do typically a better job
but they're still
perfect thanks for taking my question
pleasure dan from the uk great to hear
from you let's see if he can redeem
himself i'm gonna go to eric from cancun
who had a disastrous call last time he
called in uh eric i'm i'm giving you
another shot okay
uh-oh
eric you gotta unmute yourself my friend
oh boy going from bad to worse for eric
from cancun
eric you are on the air this is your
last chance you've got to unmute
yourself or configure your microphone
otherwise we're not going to be able to
talk
all right there it is eric from cancun
attempting to
redeem himself but it didn't work it
just didn't work
let's try um let's try kevin from
seattle kevin you're on the air
mr pacman can you hear me i can
excellent uh thanks for taking my call
um
i have a question related to
infrastructure and i don't know what
like what your opinion is on this but
i think leaving the bipartisan
infrastructure built
um leaving it idle is
very risky
like
it doesn't help biden's approval ratings
democrats approval rate especially terry
mcauliffe it doesn't help the furloughed
workers who are working to fix our
infrastructure and it sucks up so much
oxygen in congress
from other issues
and
the american people liked it by person
infrastructure built and wanted to see
and feel like
um those representing them could get
something accomplished for once so
my question is
like is there koreans credence to like
the moderate position from like a
progressive point of view like is
holding up the infrastructure bill
damaging to the material interests of
the american people yeah so i think
leaving the bill idle is bad for
everybody i think either listen
vote on the bill
kill the bill if that's what people in
congress want to do house and senate or
pass some version of the bill and it's
time to move on it's been going on for
months um these bills are by and large
popular with the american people there's
disagreements about specific elements of
it but i completely agree with you just
the the ongoing negotiation used to get
oxygen by people like uh kirsten cinema
joe manchin and others um it's not it's
it's a disaster for the american people
it's got to end and just letting it sit
idle also is wrong so either kill it or
pass it and then we've got to move on to
the next thing i agree with you 100
uh all right uh i think that i think
that's
that's all i
i think if anything i cannot wrap my
head around like what what what um
why
why um those students who are like in
opposite in opposition like why is this
like the the hill to die on um like if
we care about the the american people
then
i think we shouldn't think
the bill should be voted on based on on
its merits rather than just
i don't know those are just i don't
think they see it as a hill to die on
they're just like yeah i'm just i'm not
the people who are sort of to like just
against it which is basically
republicans joe manchin keeps talking
about it because he's using it to get
attention and he may actually ultimately
vote for it republicans aren't really
dying on the hill they're just like yeah
we don't want it so we don't support it
and then and then they move on so it's
actually doing far more damage to
democrats kevin i gotta run i appreciate
the call kevin from seattle i uh
appreciate everybody i was able to speak
to today that's gonna do it for today
we're gonna go to a break i hope to
speak to you again next time we take
live calls
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right let's get into
this week's mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com
and many of you do um let's go through
some emails that i received some
interesting ideas thoughts all sorts of
different things all right first message
today is from bryce
bryce um is thinking like a um
expert on cults quite frankly and bryce
says david is it just me or when trump
eventually passes away all the trump
supporters will be acting like he's
going to come back and resurrect like
jesus what are your thoughts uh that's
bryce from from new york
yeah i mean listen there's no question
that there are many cult-like elements
surrounding donald trump
and he is seen almost as a pseudo-deity
as a as a demigod by some of his
followers and when trump famously said i
could shoot people on fifth avenue and
not lose support he was
latching on to something very real which
is that for many of his followers the
facts don't really matter it's the idea
of trump that they care about now
when trump eventually passes away
will people
literally think he's going to resurrect
like jesus that's probably a little bit
of an exaggeration but not that by that
much i do think that he will be deified
in death by
whoever is still with him at that time
um you know people are still flying look
i mean just drive around in most parts
of the country you can still find some
trump 2020 flags which might even have
something added on to it like biden lost
or now let's go brandon or something
like that um
they are still deifying him in a sense
in life and i expect them to in death
literal resurrection ideology
probably not that's probably a little
too far
but
it's trump it's trump so maybe i
wouldn't ever assume the answer is uh
the answer is impossible
justin wrote to me and said microchips
are real
sir david does no one else see the
connection the reason why there are
microchip shortages for new vehicles
is that they were all used in the
production of the vaccines which with
much respect justin yeah i know justin's
kidding and there is this funny way
sometimes it's funny sometimes it's not
funny
when different conspiracy theories or
different data points come together to
foment a conspiracy theory this one's
kind of funnier we have a microchip
shortage for cars because all the
microchips are in the vaccines that okay
this one's just funny the one that's not
so funny though is the one we looked at
on monday of someone speaking at some
school board meeting and explaining that
what ties all of this stuff together who
profits from the vaccines
uh who controls the deep state all of
this different it's the jews and that
was one woman beautifully tying together
in her mind disgustingly in reality but
beautifully in her mind tying together
all of these different conspiracy
theories and saying the jews are
responsible for all this stuff we knew
that it was happening because of reports
we saw it happen very very real in a
real way over the weekend next email is
from alan
allen says in response to my video about
are there really any
anti-vaccine religions alan said you
overlooked an important point on
religious vaccine exemptions alan says
david sir i heard your segment on
religious exemptions for vaccines and
although you did a great job analyzing
the situation i think there's an
important aspect you overlooked
i was teaching at a catholic high school
until the end of last year
now i'm in a public school thankfully
and the biggest debate was on the
morality of how the vaccines were
developed and not that vaccination is
specifically against the religion what
i'm referring to is the cell lines of
aborted fetuses used in development of
the vaccines although we had a decent
percentage of our community staff
students and families get vaccinated we
had multiple people hesitant or
objecting because of the cell line usage
again this is not explicitly the
catholic faith saying the members are
forbidden from getting vaccinated but it
does introduce a lot of hesitancy which
i'm sure exists through most throughout
most christian faiths love your show
alan yeah a few people emailed me about
this and this is a good point which is
my discussion last week was about
is there actually a religion that is
just against vaccination there are
individuals who are saying because i am
against abortion and because
fetal cell lines were used in the
development of the vaccines and the
technology even though there are not
fetal cells in the injection
that
is being used by some but it's
i did miss it i should have mentioned it
i agree
but it's different than the question of
simply
it's against my religion because that
seems to allude more
to the specific teachings of religion
about vaccines and i think i should have
mentioned it i'm glad that people
emailed it about it
gareth wrote in
this is actually an important topic
gareth says
very suspect florida numbers hey david
and the crew do the florida numbers not
seem incredibly low considering the case
rate is almost 1500
yet only one death per day i've attached
a photo and
the photo is exactly what gareth
describes so there's two things going on
in florida one of them i've talked about
in florida they've done this thing
where they report the deaths on a delay
so
each week they report the deaths from
the previous week
and so it always makes it look like over
the last seven or eight days
deaths have just declined almost to zero
but it's been going on for months like
for months if you look at the recent
deaths it looks like the last seven days
are almost zero then they update it and
then it shows up again so that's one
part of it
i also more generally though
am wondering whether florida is just
lying or not fully reporting or not
collecting not collecting would be the
most
sort of realistic explanation
because the numbers just look bizarrely
low relative to what's going on in other
states we're seeing case declines in the
united states but
even the numbers more generally in
florida after this seven day kind of
like holding period
um it looks weird it looks weird so i
think if we're going to say
florida is lying we really need evidence
but i think that what we could suspect
is
given florida's lack of concern at the
governor's level
for controlling kovid
and given desantis's lack of interest
in being particularly transparent
we know this based on that person who
was fired for putting together the covet
dashboard that more accurately reported
the data
it wouldn't be shocking if there's just
a sort of like ah we don't really care
about fully reporting not someone going
in and saying lie change these numbers
but
it wouldn't surprise me if there was
sort of like an indifference and there
wasn't full reporting currently going on
certainly possible
um tommy wrote to me about trump rallies
and said hi david i think you're going
to find this quite interesting yet every
time i see a trump rally
i see the same two people in the
background one is a black guy with a
white shirt saying blacks for trump and
the guy beside him is wearing a green
shirt
veterans for trump now there's uh two
different rallies they're both behind
trump here are the photos by the way
love your show yet tommy is completely
right
that veterans for trump i'm less sure of
but we're seeing um
some of the same
supposed blacks for trump supporters
show up at multiple rallies
my position on this is as follows
when you try to find information about
blacks for trump as a group there's
almost nothing on the internet there's
just you try to figure out who's
who are the members who's in charge what
is the group what exactly do they do
you find essentially nothing so the
reaction for many is this is a fake
group
and the campaign is paying black people
to stand behind trump during rallies to
make it seem like he has black support
now i've stopped short of saying that
because i don't know that to be true
and for me it feels a little weird to
basically say
a movement of minority folks
claiming to have a particular position
is by definition astro turf or fake
unless i have real evidence that that's
what's going on i'm not comfortable
saying that it feels weird to me
but in terms of data points we do know
that the group blacks for trump has
almost no footprint
um online which is strange in 2021
that there are times where it's seen
it's been alleged that
uh trump affiliated groups have been
recruiting what are essentially actors
people to stand holding signs at events
not saying they were recruiting black
folks specifically but we have that as a
data point and some of the same people
appear at multiple of these rallies so
that's what we know i'm not ready to say
it's all paid actors but we've gotten a
number of emails about this and it
certainly seems as though there may be
something too
it's not clear how real blacks for trump
is as an organization i'm completely
comfortable saying that next email is
from andrew and it's called covid the
new culture war
hello david says andrew i believe that
covid is the new culture war among
republicans such as the whole merry
christmas culture war when i didn't know
of anyone on the left who really cared
if somebody used merry christmas or
happy holidays at least the merry
christmas culture war wasn't deadly
as today's republicans have literally
entered into a death cult
also i think all these police officers
quitting for refusing the vaccine is a
good thing since the majority of them
support trump and as a result the police
brutality rate will most likely go down
a few people have actually emailed me
that saying aren't the cops quitting
over the vaccine thing exactly the cops
that we've been saying are the bad
apples that we want out anyway i don't
know that for sure
but it's a very interesting hypothesis
which is when we talk about police
brutality etc
i believe we accurately say it's a very
small minority of bad apples
which can spoil the bunch for sure
if there's overlap between the police
brutality people
and the cops refusing to get the vaccine
maybe we benefit from them quitting and
no longer being police officers it's a
hypothesis folks it's a hypothesis
that's all we're saying terms of the the
left doesn't really care about merry
christmas or happy holidays
i i agree i've never met anyone who
expressed being angry about merry
christmas being said at a store what i
would always do without getting offended
just as like a kind of joke
is if someone said merry christmas to me
i would say happy hanukkah i wasn't mad
i didn't later complain it's just my
immediate reaction they're saying
something to me based on what they
celebrate so i resp i don't celebrate
christmas but i respond saying happy
hanukkah and if it's not relevant to
them maybe the next time they go oh
maybe i'll say happy holidays because
merry christmas might not be or it's
it's like no big deal i just kind of
found it funny it's how i entertain
myself at grocery stores uh but yeah
i've never met anyone who was like mad
or said i need to speak to the manager
someone said merry christmas it is a
trump top culture war uh for sure
okay last email today this is a
different one we had a lot of
substantive emails positive emails
questions comments this is mark mark
writes to me about garbage and says your
left-wing garbage and propaganda is the
root or the root as some say of
everything wrong with our country you
have no business being on the air you
are garbage that is mark presented
without comment
as we get into what will hopefully be a
great weekend for everybody thanks for
joining me we've got a fantastic bonus
show planned for you and we will be back
next week with so much more
sign up at joinpacman.com get instant
access to today's bonus show otherwise
no more new content until monday when
we'll be back with our next show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa i have two all
form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get 20 off when you go
to allform.com
pacman